[Music]
a family searching for answers tonight
they say it's been nearly three weeks
since they heard from their sister now
they have questions for those who were
with her last victoria saha spoke with
the family about the search for 24 year
old brianna davis victoria joins us from
the newsroom now with their story
brianna davis family is hoping someone
will see this report and recognize her
they're doing everything they can to
find her but their hands are tied
because they're in california and they
say those davis was living with aren't
giving them concrete answers
she has a smile out of this world
a smile that will make you happy as well
a smile brianna davis sister desperately
wants to see again everybody is pretty
stressed out and scared anxious
and we're terrified essence rahab says
her sister moved from california to las
vegas with her boyfriend back in
february the sisters would talk every
single day up until march 31st she's
also like not on social media or
anything that's definitely not like her
she keeps up with our stories rahab says
it was only a few days ago when davis
boyfriend let others know she was quote
kind of missing that instantly raised
arms for us but rahab says davis
boyfriend keeps giving them different
answers saying she was picked up in the
middle of the night and then saying she
walked to the nearest 7-eleven and never
came home no contact no one's seen her
the boyfriend is acting very suspicious
he's not answering our phone calls they
say davis did not have a car and the
family did come this past weekend to
look for her
but no luck in the meantime they have a
message for davis we love you and if
anybody has her or if anybody is holding
her
please let our sister go just want her
home and we want her safe
i did reach out to davis boyfriend we
let him know we are helping the family
find davis he at first laughed and then
told me to call him back which i did but
he didn't answer las vegas metro police
is aware of davis disappearance if you
know anything please contact the number
on the bottom of your screen in the
newsroom victoria zaha live local now